veamos la reacción de hidrogenación de
alc y nos hemos visto esta reacción
antes con al que nos y hay algunas
similitudes y algunas diferencias veamos
qué es lo que pasa aquí empezamos con
nuestro alquiló nuestro triple enlace y
añadimos nuestro al 1 de hidrógeno y
añadimos ya sea uno o los dos
equivalentes más de nuestro al uno de
hidrógeno y el hidrógeno y el halógeno
se añadirán en lados opuestos y el
halógeno se añadirá al carbono más
sustituido este halógeno de aquí se
añadirá al carbono más sustituido el
cual en términos de región química
continuaré escribiendo aquí le dije o
mica
eso era llamado regla b
cof
me cof
añadiremos el halógeno al carbono más
sustituido en la reacción con dos
equivalentes acabarás con dos halógenos
en el mismo carbono así
veamos uno de los mecanismos propuestos
para la hidrogenación de 'la kilos y se
asemeja bastante a la hidrogenación de
al que nos y este no es considerado el
mecanismo perfecto para el kilos pero
empezaremos con eso sólo para mostrar
porque esto es de marco físico en
términos de región química digamos que
este era el mecanismo
empezamos con nuestro alquilo y tenemos
nuestro alero de hidrógeno nuestro
alumno de hidrógeno así y cuando hicimos
este mecanismo para el que nos dijimos
que la primera cosa que pasa es que
estos electrones en este enlace formarán
un enlace con este protón de aquí y
luego estos electrones mandarán estos
electrones actual o gen o así veamos qué
podemos hacer digamos que el hidrógeno
se añade al lado derecho por lo que
ahora sólo hay un doble enlace entre mis
dos carbonos y el hidrógeno se añadió al
carbono de la derecha así
y entonces ahora este carbono en la
derecha tiene un enlace yendo hacia
abajo así y ahora este carbono en la
izquierda tiene sólo tres enlaces eso le
da una carga formal de más 1 así y luego
nuestro halógeno
tendrá una carga formal de menos 1 y
entonces nuestro halógeno actuará como
nuestro núcleo filo y nuestro carbono
cargado positivamente de aquí actuara
como nuestro electro filo y entonces
tendrás al halógeno añadiendo sea ese
carbono
y ya que un kart vocación estuvo
involucrado en el mecanismo esa es la
razón por la que vemos la regla de marco
técnico porque quieres formar el kart
vocación más estable posible
el carb ocasión más sustituido es el más
estable este realmente no es el
mecanismo correcto y la razón por la
cual no es el mecanismo correcto es
porque si éste fuera el mecanismo
correcto la velocidad de esta reacción
dependerá de la concentración de las
moléculas y molecular si fuéramos a
escribir la ley de velocidad para este
mecanismo diríamos bien espero que en la
velocidad de reacción para la
hidrogenación de alki nos tenemos una
velocidad constante allí que es
proporcional a la concentración de to al
'chino'
y luego la concentración de tu alumno de
hidrógeno
dos cosas porque eso es lo que empezamos
en este mecanismo teníamos nuestro
haluro de hidrógeno
justo aquí y tuvimos nuestro alquilo
y eso no se observa experimentalmente
por lo que este mecanismo no es del todo
correcto este mecanismo no es realmente
lo que pasa pero es algo importante
pensar en este carbono como si fuera el
que está cargado positivamente y en que
se aplica la regla de markoff micov
ayuda a pensar en este mecanismo pero
este mecanismo no está del todo bien
porque esta no es la ley de velocidad
experimental la ley de velocidad
experimental resulta ser de segundo
orden con respecto actual uno de
hidrógeno y de tercer orden en general
si pones un súper índice tosa y es de
hecho dependiente de dos moléculas de
tua luro de hidrógeno y una molécula de
tu alquilo ya que es de hecho de tercer
orden en general necesitamos utilizar un
mecanismo diferente
veamos el mecanismo que está propuesto
actualmente como el mecanismo para la
hidrogenación de alc y nos empezamos con
nuestro alquilo aquí y necesitamos dos
moléculas de nuestro haluro de hidrógeno
aquí hay una molécula de nuestro haluro
de hidrógeno así
y continuamos dibujando la otra aquí
abajo
bien pongamos esos pares libres de
electrones así
en este mecanismo todas estas tres
moléculas están reaccionando al mismo
tiempo como estos electrones de aquí del
enlace entre el hidrógeno y el halógeno
el halógeno tomará esos electrones y se
moverán y formarán un nuevo enlace con
este carbono
al mismo tiempo de que eso pasa estos
dos electrones formarán un enlace con
este protón
y luego estos electrones se moverán al
halógeno así
si fuéramos a dibujar el estado de
transición de todo esto pasando al mismo
tiempo continuemos y pongamos nuestros
soportes aquí así que es lo que pasará
bien tendremos carbono doblemente
enlazado a otro carbono así y luego
tendremos muchos enlaces parciales aquí
usamos un color diferente para enlaces
parciales tenemos nuestro hidrógeno y
nuestro halógeno y luego tenemos nuestro
hidrógeno y nuestro halógeno aquí arriba
y luego usamos azul para enlaces
parciales este halógeno está formando un
enlace con este carbono de aquí
al mismo tiempo este enlace está aquí
así y empezamos con un triple enlace
pero ese triple enlace se está yendo
para formar un enlace por aquí con este
protón así
al mismo tiempo este protón se está
uniendo con este halógeno así todo esto
es un estado de transición gigante y si
piensas en lo que está pasando la razón
por la que quería mostrar este mecanismo
de arriba es para mostrarte si esto paso
paso a paso entonces este carbono en la
izquierda obtendrá toda la carga
positiva déjame solo resaltar eso este
carbono en la izquierda obtiene tu carga
positiva completa esta de aquí y
entonces si pensamos en lo que está
pasando en este mecanismo de aquí abajo
no es exactamente lo mismo pero ya que
el enlace está dejando este carbono en
la izquierda el enlace triple está
dejando este carbono en la izquierda
este es el que obtendrá algo de carácter
carbó cateo nico parcial será
parcialmente positivo y es difícil ver
en este mecanismo como este carbono
podría ser parcialmente positivo pero
aquí arriba es fácil de ver porque el
triple enlace se rompe del carbono en la
izquierda y se va al carbono en la
derecha
esa es la razón por la cual es
importante pensar en este mecanismo esto
te da tu carácter carbó cateo nico
parcial lo cual explica la región
química marco flick o bien casi acabamos
una vez que esos electrones acaben de
moverse obtendremos nuestro al que no
formaremos nuestro al que no así y
formaremos un enlace con nuestro
halógeno aquí abajo y luego formamos un
enlace aquí arriba con ese protón y
entonces ese será el producto de nuestro
mecanismo así veamos un par de
reacciones veamos la hidrogenación de
'la kilos
empezaremos con un alquilo
continuaré dibujando lo así y recuerda
quieres hacerlo lineal alrededor de tu
aquino ya que son lineales en la primera
reacción solo añadiremos un equivalente
de nuestro al 1 de hidrógeno así añadiré
un hidrógeno y un halógeno a través de
mi triple enlace sé que eso formará un
doble enlace lo primero que haré es
contar cuántos carbonos tengo veamos 1 2
4 y 5 sé qué convertir en un alquilo de
5 carbonos a un al que no de 5 carbonos
continuemos dibujando nuestro al que no
4 y 5
en la que no estará entre estos primeros
dos carbonos de aquí en la derecha así
ese es parte de mi producto pero ahora
debo de descubrir bien a cuál de estos
dos carbonos agregó mi halógeno lo
agregó a este carbono aquí en el lado
izquierdo de mi triple enlace o agregó
ese halógeno aquí al carbono en el lado
derecho de mi triple enlace y para hacer
eso tienes que pensar en la regla de
markoff licop si lo añado al de la
derecha eso me daría un kart vocación
primario
quiero decir debes de pensar en cuál te
dará el carb ocasión más estable y el
kart vocación más estable sería tu
secundario aquí en la izquierda y
entonces ese es al que tu halógeno se
añadirá aquí en el lado izquierdo repito
de vídeos anteriores para tener muchos
más detalles de carbó cationes y
estabilidad y regla de markoff mico
hagamos la adición de dos equivalentes
de haluro de hidrógeno o sólo hazlo
exceso
aquí tienes que pensar en el hecho de
que bien una vez más estoy empezando con
5 carbonos obtendré 5 carbonos
para mi producto de aquí
y vayamos arriba a nuestra reacción
original
puedes ver si tienes dos equivalentes
acabarás añadiendo tus dos halógenos al
mismo carbono y probablemente debí de
haber dibujado esto un poco diferente en
la reacción general también exhibirá
marco único para la región química
cuando estás intentando descubrir cuál
carbono es ese
piensa en cuál sería el carb ocasión más
estable otra vez nuevamente tenemos dos
opciones el carb ocasión en el lado
izquierdo o el carbono en el lado
derecho el carbono en el lado izquierdo
nos da más estabilidad por lo que
añadiremos dos equivalentes de nuestro
halógeno aquí
de hecho formamos un día al 1 como
nuestro producto
eso es hidro alojen acción de algunos
con uno o dos equivalentes de tú al uno
de hidrógeno